i've got a photographic memory pretty
much a legal superhero
mike ross
hi
i'm rachel zane i'll be giving you your
orientation
wow you're pretty good you've hit on me
we can get it out of the way that i am
not interested no i'm sorry i wasn't
hitting on you trust me i've given
dozens of these and without fail
whatever new hot shot it is thinks that
because i'm just a paralegal that i will
somehow be blown away by his dazzling
degree let me assure you i won't
i was
i was hitting on you you were
take notes i'm not gonna repeat myself
i love you
i gave you that for a reason you haven't
taken one note it's because because you
were too busy ogling me to listen to a
word i've said
i couldn't have done it without you
you wouldn't even know where to look
without me you know what nobody likes
nobody likes a show-off
you called me sure did
have a seat
i prefer to stand
fair enough
uh i made a mistake
you were unfairly punished and i would
like to officially
just welcome you back thank you you're
welcome
are you kidding me
you think i'm gonna make it that easy on
you
i want a raise
three percent ten percent
seven ten percent
five and pearson hardman pays for law
school when i decide to go
agreed
and one more thing
this should have been the first words
out of your mouth when i walked in here
you need to apologize to me
right now
i'm going to file a lawsuit against you
first thing in the morning
you're right
i should have apologized
but don't you
threaten me
i follow procedure to the letter and you
have no basis for a lawsuit no i don't
not about this
but if you don't think i have a basis
for all the [ __ ] you've pulled over the
years i've been here
think again
i'm sorry
okay
i've got a photographic memory pretty
much a legal superhero
i can recite the constitution forwards
backwards and sideways because i read it
once when i was seven
don't buy it recite it right now
cheers
divorce is on 43.
look i know that you're mad at me
and i never meant to put you in this
situation but i would really appreciate
it if you kept what i told you to
yourself
let me get this straight
you hit on me then you run into the arms
of some married woman you come waltzing
into my office trying to cutesy your way
out of it and now you have the nerve to
think i'm gonna go and tell other people
[Music]
i have no idea what you're gonna tell
other people but you sure seem to have
the ability to judge everything that i
do you think that you have the lock on
bad decisions all i know is i'm not
little miss perfect i've had an affair
before too
see the look on your face
who's judging who now mike
and no it was not some 50 year old man
trying to take advantage of poor young
me we were the same age and i went after
him
i am not the goody goody you think i am
you have
no idea what you passed on
you got a minute
maybe
it's not about us it's about work oh
yeah
folsom foods missy dealers are paralegal
on it right yeah when she's not texting
her boyfriend every five seconds or her
roommate like every other five seconds
put me on instead
no i don't think that's a good idea the
new opposing counsel is my dad
your dad is robert zane
is it so hard to believe that my
father's black
robert zane is black you think this is a
year-round tan i know who you are but i
can't believe that your father is the
robert zane and you never said anything
to me i don't like people here knowing
oh i'm just people
i mean before with the okay
look i'm offering to help you kick his
ass are you gonna make room for me or
not
before i answer that
question do you really think it's a good
idea for you and i don't work together
are you really asking me what is or
isn't a good idea
wow
look out robert zane
screw you
mine likes to be scolded too i keep
getting these dating site pop-ups it's
like my computer's accusing me of being
single do you know why it's doing that
my mother's in there did you search for
a dating site no when
last week
what were you gonna tell me
mike were you ever gonna goddamn tell me
don't speak to me you went behind my
back when you knew how i felt about this
no i went behind your back because i
knew how you felt about it is that
supposed to make it okay
look i was the one that didn't want to
let things get too risky but when harvey
laid it out for me i decided that it
wasn't then why didn't you come to me
first because you're the one that says
forgiveness is easier to ask for than
permission that's a [ __ ] reason
then how about focusing on the fact that
i did it for you
rachel mike this morning when you told
me it was over the look on your face
i don't want you to have that look for
the rest of your life rachel i was upset
it had just happened no mike that's just
it it hadn't
you've been living with this for so long
that's why you gave harvey the go-ahead
to begin with i did that because i had
to watch oliver fail and there's nothing
i could do about it and if it wasn't
oliver it was going to be someone else
or something else there's always going
to be some reminder that you weren't a
lawyer
and it would eat away at you because
it's what you're meant to be you
shouldn't have done what you did i know
you're mad at me for going behind your
back
but i'm not gonna apologize because i
don't want to spend the rest of my life
with a man who gave up on his dreams and
i know that you don't want to be that
man either what do you need
a napkin no
social security number date of birth
favorite color allergy to nuts i don't
know what's it gonna take
i don't think i need to steal your
father's identity just yet
mike said he pulled the settlement and
we can't let that happen
we
yes we i work here too
now i get it
okay no no no this this isn't isn't
about me and my father this is about the
client you know i meant why donna likes
you so much
oh
thank you i i like her too uh you know
what
i was gonna give in and drop this case
but now that you accosted me during my
me time i'm gonna change my mind and do
what you said
you were gonna continue with it anyway
yes right
would you like to eat my bagel now too
oh
thank you
i'm so sorry
thank you
are you ready for round two i am
in fact i
think i already won because one of the
easiest things to do in a debate is to
attack the debater
what is this you went after me because
of something that my fiance did but the
truth is
we all have skeletons in our closets the
difference between you and me
is that i don't care to use them
what do you want
i think you know what i want shall we
get started
i'd like to apologize
for saying what i said to rachel zane i
only did what i did because she's my
intellectual and ethical superior
i'm ashamed of myself
and i forfeit this competition
how'd you get her to say that doesn't
matter
what matters is everyone here knows that
i'm not afraid of her
i take it that means you're staying in
the class then nope
that is my official dropout request
i'm doing the innocence project
mr bailey my name is rachel zane i am a
law student at columbia and i'm here to
talk to you about your case student yes
we work alongside the innocence project
to determine if you have the criteria
for an appeal do you know how long i've
been sitting on death row 12 years i
read your file and for the last 10 of
them i've been writing letters and
begging any lawyer
to listen to my story and they finally
get around to getting back to me
and they don't even have the courtesy of
sending me a real lawyer mr bailey trust
me
i will fight for you you're a student
you can't do [ __ ] for me
well you know what you killed two people
in cold blood
you know it and i know it and that's why
you're in there so thank you for making
the decision to not take your case an
easy one you don't know me all you know
is what you read in some damn file
i didn't kill anyone
i've been saying it for 12 years and i
can prove it you're right i don't know
you
and you don't know me
either so do you want to take a chance
on each other or not
i need help
miss city
so let me help you
how are you going to get back on that
case
um i got a different case
graham stinton
the accountant who embezzled 30 million
dollars from our clients yep
and our job is to get the money back
quietly our job is in pearson darby our
job is in you and me
i'm interviewing his associate this
afternoon and i need your help
you want me to be the mic to your heart
i do want you to be the mic to my
harvard yeah well it's not really a
thing it can be
oh huh
i get to ask half the questions
harvey doesn't let mike ask after
questions fine one-third harvey doesn't
negotiate with mike mike doesn't have
sex with harvey
one third of the question seems
reasonable to me
excuse me professor dunbar do you have a
moment this is the faculty lounge miss
and you're not supposed to be in here i
understand that and i'm sorry it's just
this is important and you weren't in
your office
what can i do for you i met with leonard
bailey yesterday he's the inmate i know
who he is is there a problem yes there
is he's rotting on death row for a crime
that he didn't commit so you met with
him for 10 minutes and you're ready to
release him no what i'm saying you're a
second-year law student rachel
i asked you to be a part of this because
you're one of my brightest students but
i also asked you in particular because
i didn't think you'd be so naive excuse
me your job wasn't to talk to mr bailey
once and after being moved by his tale
of woe tell me to jump him to the top of
the pile it was to assess his case and
present evidence and that's exactly what
i'm doing here i just left two boxes of
textbook prosecutorial misconduct with
your secretary you found
all of that since yesterday yes because
while i may only be a second-year law
student i had been a practicing
paralegal for the past eight years
looks like i have some reading to do
i'm sorry for interrupting your day good
afternoon miss sane
good afternoon
how it professors
[Music]